over the last 10 years Hollywood has
clearly figured out how to make big
screen superheroes work putting together
incredibly successful adaptations of
characters and worlds that comic fans
loved before that though well let's just
call it trial and error the path to the
MCU is littered with strange efforts
that have gone mostly forgotten since
they were originally released here are
the bizarre Marvel TV shows you've
probably never seen Generation X 1996 in
an era when the x-men franchise has a
sprawling series of movies and TV hits
like the gifted and Legion it's hard to
believe that there was a time in which
Marvel's mutants weren't too sure thing
in the 90s the core team was thriving in
comics and ruling Saturday mornings with
a long-running animated series and a
spin-off called Generation X featured a
younger cast of heroes still learning
the ropes in a time before Buffy the
Vampire Slayer hit airwaves with a
supernatural spin on a similar idea
Generation X sounds like the perfect way
to bring Marvel's edgy 90s teen drama to
television
it wasn't filmed as a pilot and aired as
a TV movie Generation X is a
hallucinogenic nightmare and not the
good kind the production value is
insanely low the acting is lousy and
somehow it doesn't even manage to be
entertaining me bad instead it's mostly
just a reminder of how lucky we are to
have better stuff today Silver Surfer
1998 in the 90s Marvel had huge success
with cartoons like x-men and spider-man
but there were plenty of other attempts
at an animated Marvel Universe that
ended after a single season 1998 Silver
Surfer animated series however could
have been remembered as one of the best
the surfer is an inherently weird
character of cosmic Sentinel whose
stories are often bright with themes of
existentialism and philosophical
struggle rather than tone it down for
the show and turn it into a simple beat
him up about good guys and bad guys the
animators leaned into it with episodes
about imperialism slavery and nihilism
it also incorporated some of the
strangest characters the cosmic side of
the Marvel Universe has to offer
including Gamora
who want to The Watcher eternity and
even Thanos
art-style was interesting too with
imperfect but charming cgi that looks
like it's rip street from the pages of a
Jack Kirby comic unfortunately a legal
dispute between Marvel and Saban the
production company led to the show's
cancellation after a single season it's
a shame too well it was one of the
strangest Marvel shows of all time it
was also one of the most interesting The
Avengers
United they stand 1999 looking back from
a time when there in the most popular
movies ever made it's hard to imagine a
show about the Avengers being so
unpopular that it was canceled after a
single season
if you've ever seen Avengers United they
stand however they'll understand exactly
why it got the X rather than including
popular heavy hitters like Thor Captain
America and Iron Man the show was
populated by heroes that were be
Lister's at best we're not knocking
great characters like Hawkeye on the
Falcon but Tygra and the swordsman
aren't exactly the biggest names Marvel
had to offer on the other hand topping
that team off with a genuine stinker of
a character in Wonder Man is a recipe
for disaster
and giving everyone clunky toy attic
designs rather than their iconic comic
book costumes wasn't a help either
yikes played this series 2006 let's give
credit where it's due
blade effectively kick-started the
modern superhero movie and Blade 2 still
holds up as one of the best the Jon
rahat offer will admit that blade
Trinity might be an imperfect conclusion
to the trilogy but overall blade rules
with that in mind it's no surprise that
in 2006 Spike TV began developing a
series continuing The Adventures of the
legendary daywalker
unfortunately the show lacked the budget
production values and star power of the
big screen version Wesley Snipes was
absent replaced by sticky Fingaz of the
rap group onyx and none of the other
actors in the films appeared in the
series either it never quite felt like
the blade of the movies and ran for one
very strange season before it ultimately
got staked through the heart after 13
episodes soup Ida man 1978 to 1979
there's an undeniable charm to Japanese
club Kusatsu shows
genre has a long tradition in Japan of
colorful costumed heroes fighting
grotesque monsters and giant robots and
America has been importing it for
decades now in the form of the
long-running Power Rangers franchise all
the more interesting though is the time
the reverse happened in Japan brought an
American hero to a tokusatsu show as
part of a licensing agreement to weigh
the leading producer of tokusatsu in
Japan made his show loosely based on
spider-man in the late 70s often
transliterated as super Heidemann to
distinguish it from the original japan's
take resembles its source material and
name and costume only instead of Peter
Parker Spidey is Takuya Yamashiro a
daring motorcycle racer who got his
powers from the blood of a dying alien
from Planet Spider he's tasked with
fighting a sinister interstellar force
called the iron cross army led by the
evil professor monster oh and Spidey's
got a giant robot called leo pardon
Supai the man is all kinds of awesome if
you're into tokusatsu and also super
weird thanks to scenes where supe
Heidemann introduces himself as an
emissary from hell or shoots at people
with a machine gun but he also has a
place in koku history
he was the first live-action to
introduce a hero summoning a giant robot
which would become a mainstay in Super
Sentai and Power Rangers afterward
Nightman 1997 to 1999 the ultraverse
line is a pretty odd slice of 90's
comics these original superhero comics
were published by a company called
Malibu which was acquired by Marble in
1994 but not before a few of their
heroes had been optioned for mass media
along with the short-lived animated
series about a team called ultra force
that was half satire and half rip off of
the far more successful x-men the major
result was Night Man which ranks among
the most peculiar superhero shows of all
time the series focuses on a buff jazz
saxophonist who develops the telepathic
ability to detect evil after being
struck by lightning at the cost of never
being able to sleep with eight hours of
his day freed up he creates a super suit
and starts fighting crime at night that
last part is probably obvious it's a
stretch above premise to begin with and
coupling it with laughable production
values it makes for a pretty freaky
show some how it managed to last for two
seasons and reeled in guest stars like
Jerry Springer and Donald Trump a slice
of pure 90s weirdness ninth man is
mostly forgotten but give the opening
credits one watch and will promise it's
all you're going to think about for a
week
mutant ex 2001 to 2004 Mutant X is the
product of poor circumstance to make a
long story short Marvel sold the film
and TV rights for the x-men to 20th
Century Fox years later Marvel Studios
producer avi arid pushed Mutant X into
production and was promptly sued by Fox
for violating their agreement by putting
x-men characters in a TV show Fox didn't
produce which was a pretty big deal
after the success of the first x-men
movie because of this changes were
applied to distance Mutant X from its
source material resulting in a genuinely
bizarre show that's not quite an x-men
show but not quite not the show is about
a group of mutants who gained their
powers through a government experiment
the show follows them while they're on
the run and being kept safe by one of
the scientists that helped create them
the characters were unrelated to the
x-men none of them were allowed to have
super heroic code names and the only
real resemblance to the real x-men is
the presence of mutants and the team's
mission is to find other mutants and
help keep them safe
despite its general weirdness the show
ran for three seasons before its
production company folded